hey guys i've got very big news
i'm changing the name of dlm model
lifestyle yeah it's very big news
will the whole channel change no it'll
be exactly the same
but with new and interesting content
[Music]
oh it's going crazy
[Music]
so what's the new channel name well
let me show you with the new intro you
ready
let's go three two one
[Music]
welcome to dlm men's lifestyle
it's still focused on fitness grooming
style and
life but with a renewed focus
on men so especially in the life part
of the channel we're gonna bring you
some very interesting and new
type of content everything has got to do
with men one of the reasons why i'm
changing the name of the channel is
because
i'm not the same guy i used to be
anymore back when i started the channel
when i was modeling in asia skinny
very skinny and i'm not going back to
asia again for modeling
so i don't need to be that skinny and
that's why i gained a lot of muscle
and this is the way that i'm going to
stay so you're going to see some more
interesting
fitness content coming very soon now i'm
not quitting modeling
100 but i'm going to do a lot less
modeling only for good quality
and trustworthy brands i'm not going to
go to castings anymore
just focus i'm just going to focus on
direct bookings because a lot of things
changed over the
last three years i don't have time to do
full-time modeling and then run two
youtube channels
i just don't have enough time so thank
you guys so much
for this last three years we've grown
from zero to over 750
000 subscribers it's all thanks to you
guys
and now our aim is one million so get
ready for new and interesting
men's content i'll see you guys in the
next video
cheers